hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled ultra fast one step
rtpcr protocol for the detection of
stars cov2 this webinar is part of the
coronavirus
virtual event series and i'm susie
valdez of labrutz and i will be
your moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab roots so let's get started before we
begin i want to remind everyone that
this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as
many questions as you'd like during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
simply click on that ask a question box
on the far
left of your screen as a reminder the
presentation is educational and offers
free continuing educational credits
click on the continuing education
credits tab located on the top right
corner
of your presentation window and follow
the process
to obtain those credits i now present
today's speaker dr
brian mcnally chief commercial officer
of molecular biology systems
bb for complete biography on our
speakers please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen dr mcnally
welcome
you may now begin your presentation
good day my name is brian mcnally i'm
chief commercial officer at molecular
biology systems
and i'll be speaking today around the
topic of ultra-fast rt-pcr for the
detection of sars kobe 2
in the coronavirus webinar series
molecular biology systems uh is a
company that started in 2015
uh that's based in the netherlands that
has developed a next-generation pcr
device so
we'll talk about it some of the studies
that have been used around the world
with the device
so as this audience is acutely aware of
the pandemic that's
going on the number of headlines that
have been occurring over the course of
the summer
that detail essentially how throughput
of laboratory testing is impacting
clinical value
starting in sort of late july bill gates
came out with the statement that
delays in coronavirus testing result and
a complete waste of efforts and
they're insane um and i think this is
probably best
documented by 40 of us covet 19 tests
uh are coming back too late to be clean
clinically meaningful
based off of the fact that getting test
results
uh is essentially occurring uh too late
in the window where they
the individual could then be uh
infectious and then
getting other people sick and the
backlog then is obviously
making a headache for a number of uh
efforts around the united states around
the world where for instance florida
dropped a laboratory provider when a
backlog of 75
000 tests was recognized so there have
been some
papers that have come out uh challenging
whether or not we should make
compromises in laboratory testing around
the
difference between speed of results and
sensitivity
in med archives there's a paper release
called test sensitivity secondary to
frequency and turnaround time for cova
19
surveillance and they did some modeling
in the paper where they contrast
surveillance testing with
true diagnostic clinical testing if you
will
and the authors concluded at the end of
their uh publication that turn around
time and frequency should be
uh prioritization
if you take the combination of these
headlines and
this sort of suggested uh strategy that
would suggest that
testing rate the you know the actual
testing is a key performance indicator
for
addressing testing within this pandemic
so what what would be sort of the
benefits that we would recognize
from faster testing protocols well
first of all obviously faster testing
leads to faster results
and then faster results of course can
improve clinical decision making
uh notably the decision about an
individual should corn not
then of course uh increasing test
capacity then
per unit time allows any individual
laboratory
to then process more samples if they can
process
additional samples that could then
result in more frequent testing of
individuals
that has been recognized as something
that would be needed for us to get back
to work
and then of course if you can increase
the number of tests that are
accomplished per unit time
the associated labor and overhead costs
that are associated with testing would
be reduced on a per test basis
so if we have these benefits and we have
these
recommendations and these challenges
within it how can we
go about doing this and i thought the
best way to introduce this
concept would be to look at the total
workflow as it is now
first we have the collection of samples
and then we'd look at preparation
amplification detection of signal
uh the analysis of the sample results
and then finally any sort of delivery of
information to
uh information systems so
if you look at this then we have an
opportunity to look at where
are potential time savings that could be
realized and so
we can see that what's happened so far
this summer is there's been a real focus
on collection and preparation
notably in the collection uh whether or
not we can trans uh
transfer from a health practitioner with
a nasopharyngeal swabs or something more
like a mid-turbinate swab or an anterior
nerve swab that would allow for soft
collection
to extend that there's been a focus on
saliva as a sample type due to its
convenience and
at home testing possibilities or at-home
collection possibilities
the next though is around preparation
and you can see that
preparation for rna isolation protocols
typically takes 30 to 90 minutes
uh the 30 to 90 minute window for a
processing for instance 48 or
96 samples using automated robots
so in reaction to that there have been a
number of efforts by both
companies as well as universities to
develop solutions like lysis reagents
uh and that would create crude lysates
of viral rna
that would then be paired or used
together with inhibitor tolerant pcr
chemistries or direct to pcr
or rt pcr chemistries and both of these
have resulted in time
savings but when we're doing an analysis
of looking at what the long arm of this
process are
amplification clearly stands out as one
of the things that doesn't seem to have
been greatly impacted
are in our response to pandemic testing
and so the question is are there any
methods that are available for
decreasing this sort of
70 to you know two and a half hour
window of amplification
well there's uh certainly literature
evidence that suggests
that uh this can be done there is
additionally
a point of care device uh type of
methodologies
uh that can do single sample
acceleration down into sort of the 15
minute window
but those are you know poorly suited for
dealing with thousands if not
millions of samples that need to be
tested
when we look at the literature though um
there have been publications for
instance shown here on the left where
there was a
three step or a three temperature pcr
that underwent 30 cycle
30 cycles of amplification in less than
two minutes
um that technology was deployed by a
group of dutch researchers
in a paper that was published earlier
this year the journal of microbiological
methods
published a paper called fast
identification of e coli and urinary
tract infections
using next generation pcr
and what i think is notable about this
publication is that
what we can see is that their total a
workflow time
they listed as 52 minutes but it
included also dna extraction
pcr electrophoresis then the staining
and de-staining of those gels and then
finally the visualization of that gel
under uv light so
with that in mind if we broke out just
the number that they said for the
cycling it was a 16 minute protocol so
it suggests that there's methods
available for accelerating
thermocycling by next generation pcr
so what is next generation pcr
and we can start with looking at a
history of thermocylin
of course the early you know pcr
reactions use
water baths where three water baths were
set up
for um denaturing annealing and
extension
of oligos and extension by a dna
polymerase
and then a tube with a reaction mixture
was then
um you know moved between these three
water baths
uh you know by a manual process
this process was then automated by
putting it into a
machine where then many reactions could
be then put into a pcr plate and this
was all put into a peltier block
and this thermocycle is then
accomplished by heating and cooling that
metal block that then trim
so next generation pcr accelerates a
thermocycling using
two mechanisms and the they're comprised
by
looking at the figures on the left-hand
side where we see first
the lines that are diagonal between the
resting
those would represent the ramp rates
that occur during pcr cycling
and then of course there's the
individual steps themselves that are
highlighted
in red blue and gray and those would be
the
resting steps in each of the zones if
you can
decrease to the point of elimination the
ramp time
you can then result in a figure that's
shown in there on the right
and that elimination of ramping rates
for typical pcr
protocols can result in a forty to sixty
percent time savings
if you can then further decrease the
length of time that a reaction stays at
each step
then you can also then decrease the
protocol even further
this is accomplished by next generation
pcr by
two mechanical actions the first is
i'm going to be then moving the plate
between three temperature zones and so
i'm going to show you a video coming up
where there's going to be a plate that's
going to start on the left hand side of
the machine
and it's going to move into the machine
proper
and they're going to be a pair of blocks
there's three pairs of blocks the top
white and the bottom are yellow and
it's going to shift between them it'll
be in red
as it goes through each of these pairs
of blocks the white and yellow
are set to a specific enter either
denaturation
annealing or extension the plates of the
blocks will come together and compress
the plate
and then subsequently compress the wells
that are within each plate
and so i'm going to go ahead and start
the video now you're going to watch
again the plate come in from the left
and cycle through and then at the
completion of the video i'm going to
walk you through
the what the ramifications of
compressing the plate area
okay
okay
so as we saw in the video we can
eliminate the ramp rates by
using the action of moving the plate
between three temperature zones
but i also refer to the compression of
the plate
by the blocks as another way to
accelerate pcr
the plates themselves are a rigid frame
that you can see here shown on the left
hand side that then have
a ultra thin plastic sheet that then is
laid over top of them where the wells
are then formed into that sheet
the my the ultra thin plastic is about
50 microns thick
and the wells are then laid out in a
standard sps format in either 96 or 384
well formats and then can be
various well volumes after a reaction is
then dispensed
into the well then there's a optical
ready or an optically clear
film that isn't heat sealed on top of
the plate before it's placed into the
machine
when the with this in mind then when
those blocks compress
these wells actually uh deform and the
liquid inside's been shown to mix and
therefore
when the two very large thermal masses
of the blocks compress this plate
squeeze the liquid thin the transfer of
heat is not just
uh to the outside of the well but it's
throughout the entire reaction mixture
and it changes the temperature almost
instantly therefore there's not the need
for these long dwell periods of
for instance 30 seconds or a minute at
particular steps
and we can draw those down to something
that's more like two seconds
five seconds 10 seconds in order to
decrease the protocol
further we went ahead and paired that
together
then with um and deployed that to a
research group at the university of
bielefeld in germany
led by christian call schmidt who then
accumulated some results that were
published earlier this year in med
archives
in a paper titled ultra fast one step
rtpcr
protocol for the detection of sars kobe
2.
what you can see below the title there
is a picture of one of those 9612 plates
that then has been imaged on a
fluorescent imaging system
like a gel documentation system that
then clearly picked up
a fluorescein signal and then you can
see the green and red outlines in those
wells indicating positive and negative
samples
based off of the threshold overall the
paper was able to find a couple of key
findings
they took w-h-o published
assays and accelerated them in 96 well
plates
with protocols including the reverse
transcription step
that resulted in a 16 minute protocol
if you look at all three assays that
were tested within the paper
they had a 96.6 sensitivity with
remnant clinical samples that were used
at one-fifth the recommended volume
suggesting a very sensitive detection
method
now this methodology is a single target
assay um that highlights an effective
screening protocol that could be used
and in the image that i showed here on
the left it's with one of the uscdc
design
assays with an fda cleared master mix
that has been uh that was used in the
paper
so overall the procedure looked
something like this in the paper where
they
selected the plates in this case they
selected a 96 well plate that had a 20
microliter reaction volume of course
they come in different plate sizes and
reaction numbers but they're all sps
format and can be used with liquid
handlers
they then use the optically clear films
that i alluded to earlier to seal it in
a heat sealer
using an anvil to then create a seal
around each
reaction chamber so there's no
cross-contamination
after putting into the thermocycler for
16 minutes that accomplished the reverse
transcription
as well as the cycling they took the
plate
flipped it over and put it onto a blue
led light imager for fluorescent
detection
after capturing that image a simple jpeg
file
they then used a software package to
analyze the fluorescent data and convert
it into
uh raw fluorescent units that were then
able to be put into for instance
an expert with the analysis of a simple
table and so what you can see here is
then a table that corresponds to the
wells
uh where their fluorescent values were
captured for each of the different wells
this data then could be converted into
an analysis software you could look at
threshold values you could deliver it to
a for instance a laboratory information
system
they continued this and for instance one
of the programs that they
accelerated was the shards hay protocol
that was published
earlier this year with an assay
targeting starscope v2
using the quantum bio q script xlt
rt master mix and they did a nice
dilution series
here with the synthetic rna supplied by
twist bioscience
and you can see in the figure on the
left hand
side there's sort of a decrease in
amounts of copies per reaction
with the top row being the no template
control representing the background of
the reaction
and then above the plate you can see the
cycling conditions where
there was an rt step followed by uh
then a heating activation of the rt
reaction and then a 40 cycle protocol
and so as they went through this they
were then able to uh
then create a cutoff by
taking the average fluorescent value
across the no template control
adding three times the standard
deviation to create a threshold value so
they could call positive and negative
samples
the same approach then you know the
question becomes what is the analytical
sensitivity of a method like this
and in one of the examples um they've
gone ahead and
put together a figure that's shown here
on the left where they looked at the
analytical sensitivity
of the china cbc developed assays
against
orf1ab as well as the n gene
and by using a dilution series and then
seeing where it crossed the threshold
value
you can see a really great analytical
sensitivity of
about two and a half and about four and
a half copies per microliter
the same result the same type of curves
were also done for the uscdc assays the
duros and charity assays as well as
acids from the institute pasteur
so this kind of provides some uh
support for using uh the assay for as a
sensitive methodology but
what would it look like for instance in
practice
and so now uh in collaboration with
groups
in suriname and molecular biology
systems
deployed three units um there are three
machines
and they've done a large uh study with
clinical
narrative geoswabs that were collected
and first tested with a roche light
cycler or a g
expert to a den and to identify their
identities and samples and what you can
see then
is on the right hand side a scatter plot
that then
compares the relative fluorescent units
into assay from the uscdc on next-gen
pcr
as it relates to the ct value that was
derived from the n assay
on a roche light cycler and what i've
drawn in the red lines there for you is
uh the one that's
um crosses right around 50 58
60 relative fluorescence units above
that was considered
positive by next-gen pcr uh and
fluorescent detection
and then the vertical line represents
the ct threshold cutoff that they're
using for this assay of 38
and so that you can see then if you
analyze the deposit percent agreement
there was 116 out of 121 samples were
correctly
identified and there was a 100 negative
percent agreement over 350 samples
suggesting that this protocol is
something that could be used
um with authentic samples
now when we think about this protocol in
a little bit more detail what we see is
that these are singleplex assays
and most of the assays that have been
used within the community
are multiplex assays testing either
multiple viral targets or the
incorporation of process controls or
human rna controls and so if we think
about that
it really becomes a matter of looking at
this detection bubble as whether or not
there's some way
to uh pair that together with the
amplification in a way that
allows for even higher throughput so as
i
alluded the previous studies all
demonstrated singleplex readouts and now
the question is is there a methodology
that could then do the same with a
multiplex readout
of course what i'm going to show you now
is a process that then replaces that gel
documentation system that
sort of blue led light and then works
with
a image or a fluorescent plate reader
the fluorescent plate reader that was
then made available
um by bmg lab tech um to laboratories in
the netherlands
um at the university of nymegan and then
of course in collaboration life science
uh performed the the work there in the
netherlands and what they use is the
next generation pcr
microplates are directly imaged so
there's uh they just take the plate out
of the thermocycler
and then put it into the bmg lab tech
flow star
and they image the 96 wheel plates with
for both fluorescein as well as hex
the scan time for the whole plate took
about five minutes the well scan uses a
5x5 matrix
and they select the grineer 96 f-bottom
plate setting
do the analysis now i'm going to show
you some of the data that they did there
using a
first control experiment they used a kit
by
primer design as a coven specific label
with fam there is a process control
that's included in that kit around
using hex and they started by creating
a positive sample by pooling extracted
rna from
five positive samples the ct mix
average was uh ct was uh about 20
with a standard deviation of about one
and a half and then they also used
three um negative uh samples
um as controls as well as included uh
controls for both positive and negative
and in all cases they use samples of 8
microliters with 12 microliters of
mastermix and when
these the sample was then run on a
dilution series within the quants studio
you can see the ct values there on the
right hand side
so the dilution factor um they're five
fold steps so
the first one is shown there is
essentially the samples diluted 25 times
the 625 times and so on and so forth
and the runtime for this experiment took
78 minutes
using the same cycling protocol on next
generation pcr
that protocol was on shown on the left
that would be would take about 45
minutes
compared to the 78 in the quan studio
and 87 minutes in the bio-rad cfx 96
there is then the opportunity using that
compression of wells in the next gen pcr
machine to then
accelerate that protocol further um they
developed a fast protocol in this study
that where they you can see limited the
denaturing time they cut that in
from 10 seconds to 5 and the annealing
extension time from 30 seconds to 15
and maintain the 45 cycles and so in
very preliminary results which you can
see is the dilution series and then what
was the corresponding ct value for the
quant studio on the table on the left
and then you see raw fluorescent units
that were generated using the flowstar
for both the normal protocol as well as
the fast protocol
and then those figures are then plotted
in the histogram on the right hand side
where you can see that the fluorescent
values along the y
axis and the ct values along the x-axis
a negative control was then used as a
sort of a cut off or signal
and what you can see is in an incredibly
diluted sample that there's still a
sufficient fluorescent signal to
differentiate it from
a negative sample as well as a negative
control
so when we take the this study together
you know some of the key findings are
that the
fluorescent play reader was clearly able
to directly read the next generation pcr
microplates next generation pcr
successfully cycled a multiplex assay
three and a half times faster
than the protocols that are currently in
use
and there is a belief by the team that
there's a further optimization of the
cycling protocol
could accelerate the assay even further
and then lastly when you look at the
dilution series and the wide range of
fluorescent values there's obviously
significant dynamic range
that then could deal with either
very very high viral loads are very low
viral lows and then in summary of what
we've shown you today
um you know when we think about the
context of how much testing do we need
there have been estimates in the united
states that we need somewhere between
200 000 and a million tests be
performed per hour in order to
successfully reach some of the estimates
of what's required
and if we look historically up to just a
few days ago the
absolute peak rate of testing was only
at about 49
50 000 samples per hour so that's less
than 25
of the stated goal by multiple uh
organizations and so if we think about
that um
you know and the impact of that
obviously the earlier statistics around
the 40 percent of tests arrive too late
to be clinically useful
um is a result of the fact that current
systems can really only perform about
132 to 250 tests per hour
and so the results that we've shared
with the community today are really
about what next generation pcr system
a single unit system could perform about
1100
test results without pooling could be
performed on a 384 well plate
um their estimates between four and
eight times faster than the current
systems
um the system which actually is shown
over my shoulder there
it only takes up about the size of two
shoe boxes
in total and they use the exact same
fda cleared assays the same fda cleared
rna extraction methods
so it's an open platform that's
available for development
so we're excited to share the studies
and the progress of the team that
um that we've been working with uh in
both
suriname um in the netherlands with uh
ice agent life sciences so we're very
excited to continue to work with the
community and
we encourage people to contact us in
relation to how they can use
an ultra fast rt pcr protocol to
accelerate
uh testing results so thanks i wish you
all
very good health and um uh if there's
any questions i'll be
logging in for the q a session later
today
so thank you very much
and thank you dr mcnelly for that
informative presentation
and we will start now the q a portion of
that webinar
if you have any questions you want to
ask please do so now just click
on that ask a question box located on
the far left
of your screen so let's get started we
have a few questions
already coming in dr mcnelly
since this is an end point sickler can
it be used for sequencing workflows
yeah that's a great question so um
the um the device itself can be used for
uh sequencing workflows uh gel
electrophoresis capillary
electrophoresis as well as this new sort
of direct detection
workflow there's a number of
organizations around the world that have
already employed it
both in sanger sequencing sequencing
workflows as well as next generation
sequencing uh sequencing workflows
thank you so much all right one
additional point
one of the things that i described
earlier on is that the plates are sealed
uh with the heat seal and to use them in
the sequencing workflow those
seals are piercible piercing with a
pipette tip so you just
remove the reaction mixture to push it
down the sequencing workflow
thank you so much and can i run my own
assays
on the next gen pcr
uh absolutely uh the next gen pcr
platform is an open platform um
as we showed in the presentation there
are a number of
uh different assays that have already
been put onto the machine you saw the
the different ones that were published
by the who for sars kobe 2
and then there have been a number of uh
ones developed by private organizations
uh that have also been run on that
machine
thank you very much we have time for one
more question can the plates be used
in liquid handlers uh
absolutely the um the nice thing about
when you're moving uh samples this fast
and doing testing this fast is you're
really going to need some sort of
automation
uh to be able to drive that workflow
consistently
as we said the the plates are sps
formats
uh they've been successfully deployed in
both the small pipetting stations as
well as in large liquid handling
platforms
for both dispensation reaction setup as
well as sample retrieval for
sequencing workflows dr mannelly thank
you again for your presentation today
and for your important research
would you like to provide any closing
remarks for our audience members before
we go
yeah just a couple of things um we did
think a couple of the teams and
obviously
i unfortunately uh you know left one out
the uh
team at the university of bielefeld has
been a great supporter of ours and
was one of the earlier doctors that we
based a lot of this literature off of so
thanks to them
um and then of course the next gen pcr
team uh
is happy to work with organizations
across the globe so we'd be uh
happy to be contacted either through the
q a session or directly through our
website
at nexgenpcr.com so i look forward to
working with all of you um so that we
can improve the rate of testing
so thanks dr mannelly thank you again
for your time
today and for your important research
before we go i want to thank our
audience members for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by our speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
and this webcast will be viewed on
demand for
six months until march 2021 libraries
will
alert you a via email when it's
available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
this live event until next time take
care
be safe and stay healthy bye